[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Álvaro Cordero el
estado colombiano y la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional
iniciaron en Caracas este 21 de
noviembre los diálogos que buscan llegar
a un acuerdo que ponga fin a décadas de
conflicto entre las dos partes un
objetivo primordial para el nuevo
gobierno de Gustavo Petro en su promesa
de brindar a Colombia la paz total es
por ello que en France 24 queremos
repasar la historia de este grupo armado
el origen del Ln está en el año 1964 en
un momento especialmente convulso para
Colombia y América Latina Colombia
acababa de atravesar un periodo de
enfrentamiento político interno conocido
como la violencia y en el resto del
continente tomó fuerza El ejemplo de la
revolución cubana de Fidel Castro y la
influencia del Che Guevara algo que
inspiró a los hermanos Fabio y Manuel
Vázquez castaño a fundar el Ln en el
departamento colombiano de Santander
este grupo tuvo la influencia de dos
corrientes el marxismo leninismo y el
catolicismo que tenía como referencia a
la teología de la liberación una
corriente en el seno de la Iglesia
Católica que nació en Latinoamérica y
que predica un acercamiento con la
población más pobre de estos países esto
atrajo a numerosos estudiantes y
sacerdotes entre los que destaca Camilo
Torres Restrepo un líder Revolucionario
que sería asesinado en 196 25 y que se
convertiría en uno de los iconos de la
organización a pesar de que en los
primeros años Se realizaron algunas
operaciones y ganaron influencia en 1973
el Ln recibió un golpe por parte del
ejército que casi termina con su
existencia tras la llamada operación
anori una ofensiva que acabó con sus
estructuras Rurales a este golpe se sumó
en 1977 el febrero que neutralizó a sus
estructuras urbanas durante estos años
la guerrilla redujo su actividad casi a
la totalidad y no pudo ser reconstruida
hasta el año
1983 bajo las órdenes de un cura español
llamado Manuel Pérez
durante su liderazgo y el de Nicolás
Rodríguez Bautista alias Gabino lln
comenzó a experimentar un proceso de
fortalecimiento el grupo se estableció
de forma permanente en zonas fronterizas
con Venezuela y se benefició de
extorsiones a compañías petroleras
multinacionales que se establecieron en
la orinoquía como Epson Mobile a ello
también se sumó una campaña de impuestos
a cocaleros y granjeros de las zonas que
dominaban y de secuestros según el
informe publicado por la comisión de la
verdad Entre 1985 y 2018 el eln ha sido
responsable del 17% de todos los
secuestros del conflicto armado
colombiano o lo que es lo mismo más de
9.500 su estructura siempre se ha
descrito como compleja lln está
compuesto por un comando central del que
forman parte 5 comandantes y por debajo
de este hay una dirección nacional
formada por 23 representantes de cada
frente sin embargo es una organización
muy territorial donde cada frente actúa
con cierta libertad esta estructura tan
horizontal ha hecho que durante las
últimas cuatro décadas hayan fracasado
hasta cinco negociaciones de todas ellas
destacan los diálogos de Tlaxcala a
inicios de la década de los 90 durante
el gobierno de César Gaviria y las
negociaciones iniciadas durante el
gobierno de Ernesto samper y continuadas
por Andrés pastrana A mediados y finales
de esa misma década que no estamos
hablando del desarme de la guerrilla no
estamos hablando de la movilización del
Ln no estamos hablando de de esos temas
estamos hablando es bueno qué es lo que
va a dar la burguesía colombiana que van
a dar los industriales en qué van a
nacer los los gremios económicos cómo
amar ver el problema Agrario como vamos
a resolver el problema de la educación
el problema de la salud nosotros
entramos creemos con toda la claridad
las negociaciones entramos es planteando
de que estamos dispuestos a una
negociación
donde el problema central no sea en sí
lo de las armas en 1998 falleció su
hasta entonces líder el cura Manuel
Pérez y la organización pasó a manos de
alias Gabino con quien Se realizaron dos
de sus mayores operaciones en 1999 El
secuestro de 180 feligreses en una
iglesia de Cali El mayor en la historia
de Colombia y El de un avión de Avianca
con 40 pasajeros sin embargo el grupo
comenzó a perder territorio e influencia
por culpa del paramilitarismo
esta pérdida de influencia los llevó a
negociar la paz con el expresidente
Álvaro Uribe sin éxito Además desde la
llegada del Siglo 21 la organización que
durante décadas se había opuesto al
narcotráfico comenzó a comercializar con
sustancias ilícitas años más tarde
durante el gobierno de Juan Manuel
Santos el Ln comenzó un quinto proceso
de paz con el estado paralelo al que se
produjo con la extinta guerrilla de las
Farc en la ciudad de Quito sin embargo
las negociaciones fueron estancándose
hasta que comienzos de 2019 el grupo
perpetró un atentado contra una escuela
de Cadetes en Bogotá que dejó 23 muertos
un acto que sirvió como pretexto para el
entonces recién elegido gobierno de Iván
Duque para finalizar unas negociaciones
que ya estaban congeladas tras más de 58
años en armas el Ln acumula a sus
espaldas según el informe de la comisión
de la verdad el 4% del total de los
asesinatos del conflicto colombiano es
decir más de 17.700 víctimas y se ha
convertido en una guerrilla
transnacional que opera entre Venezuela
y Colombia su vuelta a la mesa de
diálogo se da tras tres años en los que
ha intentado consolidar su poder en
territorios ocupados anteriormente por
las FARC con un éxito limitado y en un
contexto diferente ya que las
negociaciones serán con el primer
gobierno de izquierda en la historia de
Colombia con esto concluimos Gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
France 24.com
[Música]